heinrich heine hat vor fast 200 jahren
gesagt untertanen treue ist so ein
schönes gefühl es ist so ein wahrhaft
deutsches gefühl
und ich habe mir die mühe gemacht mal
ein bisschen nach historisch aufzulisten
warum der deutsche sich seit 500 jahren
so ziemlich alles gefallen lassen
und wer sich mal etwas nicht gefallen
lässt dann nach oben durch notiert nach
wie vor 1914 mit 23 19 33 und 39 aber
ich glaube es gibt kaum ein land ich
habe meine nation darf man ja heute
schon fast nicht mehr sagen dass ich so
viel gefallen lässt bis zum heutigen tag
kann sich die bevölkerung an
schaafs geduldig erträgt sie die
steigerung der energiepreise schaafs
geduldig erträgt sie die 7,9 prozent
wahrscheinlich sind die schon schön
gerechnet inflationsrate schaafs
geduldig erträgt der deutsche michel wie
er
meine tägliche
gehirnwäsche gib mir heute bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen ich glaube das
ist auch mein der runde ja sagen gibt da
keinen gibt da keine tatort der nicht
politisch korrekt durchgestylt ist usw
usw mehr er lässt sich sagen du hast
antifaschistisch zu sein du hast alten
anti kolonialistisch zu sein du hast
antirassistisch zu sein und so weiter
und so weiter mehr und der deutsche er
trägt es duldet dass sie weit nach ganz
fertig gehirnwäsche sagen oder nicht
dass sie jetzt im eifer des gefechts
also gehirnwäsche sehen sie wirklich
unsere täglich gesagt haben wir
versprochen und seine tägliche
gib uns heute
nein wir ihn zu diesem unfug der gender
sprache wenig zdf anschauen will ich
überhaupt noch zdf ist ja da noch viel
schlimmer als die ja das war der kleber
der hat angefangen da war es die petra
gerster mit diesem glockenschlag wo ich
mir manchmal gedacht hab ich glaube die
nachrichtensprecher neuerdings zdf
diesen jetzt
logopädie bedürftige zu mit stolz auf
deutsch gesagt es ist eine fahrt zum der
deutschen sprache und 80 prozent ist
deutschen mittel wollen es eigentlich
nicht ich kenne die umfragen gibt es
mehrere aber der deutsche mittel steht
nicht dagegen auf soll brav seine auch
milliarden gebühren er kauft weiterhin
den audi obwohl die jetzt mit audianer
in angesprochen werden aber jetzt im
moment den prozess den entsprechenden
prozess beim landgericht ingolstadt die
kirchen machen es mit das bistum
katholische bistum hildesheim gibt eine
gender fibel oder aus für gender sprache
usw und der deutsche mitteln
jemals vertreter
das volk der dichter und denker lässt
somit seiner sprache umgeht aber gut da
könnte ich ihnen jetzt zig beispiele
nennen ich lasse ich jetzt mal so bei
diesem ersten kleinen rundumschlag also
die zusammenfassung ist bürger wehrt
euch da fragen wir doch direkt mal béla
anda ob er noch ein audi kaufen würde ob
man da jetzt schon in die reben wer
gehen muss gegen dafür keine
schleichwerbung machen aber ich fahre
ich bin das sogar gut das war ja nicht
freiwillig bei audi sondern das war
erzwungen glaube ich durchs gericht
nicht dass diese sprach erweiterung dazu
kommt ich bin ja habe ich ja schon
mehrfach arbeitet als jemand der gendern
gar nicht schlecht findet weil der
deutsche michel ja wo ist die michelin
bei ihnen auf dem cover wenn ich mir da
drauf gucke also insofern
warum sollte man nur der pilot sein und
nicht die piloten einig die reifen ich
finde die ist die einschränkung ist
tatsächlich keine die die gut ist im
endeffekt und deswegen bin ich auch
dagegen aber bei ihnen ist das ja
interessant im grunde weise sie sind ja
nicht nur autor sondern sie sind ja auch
im grunde chef pädagoge und treten ja
auch als der auf und sieht lange als
eine solche aufgetreten wie zusammen ja
gab es 20 jahre das heft ist 30 jahre
chef des lehrerverbandes und ich mir
angucke passt alles in unseren schulen
schiefläuft und schief gelaufen ist dann
frage ich mich wo waren sie als es darum
ging wer tatsächlich gerechtigkeit in
schulen einzuführen wo waren sie als es
darum ging mehr ganztagsschulen
einzuführen wo waren sie als es darum
gegen mehr betreuung an den schulen
einzuführen also 30 jahre offenbar nicht
so viel gemacht und jetzt kluge worte
warten da frage ich mich was ist denn da
schiefgelaufen ist ja wohl das könnte
die auch fragen was ist in der regierung
da schief gelaufen aber jetzt geht jetzt
lassen wir mal dass ich war 20 jahre
lang haben moment moment ich war 20
jahre lang chef eines gymnasiums und das
ist eines eine schule von 42.000
deutschland also dafür ist auch noch
tief sie waren präsident des deutschen
lehrerverbands ändert 87 bis zwei jahre
verbannt aber die bildungspolitik machen
ja immer noch die länder und nicht
irgendein verband talkshows klagen dass
er beim anders
welches ja wir waren ja noch nie
geschadet
habe die politik beraten und ich habe
gesagt das außerparlamentarische berater
und ich war immer dafür dass wir ein
leistungsorientiertes schulsystem haben
keines dass eine inflation an
abiturzeugnissen usw betreibt ich habe
ein anderes verständnis von
gerechtigkeit
ich setze gerechtigkeit nicht wie sie
mit mit gleichheit gleich ich glaube da
mal unterschiedliche verständnis ich
etwas gleichheit und gerechtigkeit
ich habe hochachtung immer gehabt vor
dem hauptschul absolventen verdienen der
eine berufliche bildung gemacht der
mensch beginnt nicht ein abitur ich habe
gewarnt vergab der rat jahren aber
natürlich corona hat da jetzt manches
natürlich wieder
an pädagogische güte hochgejubelt aber
wenn ich jetzt in der zeit der abitur
der der verleihung der abiturzeugnisse
see es gibt ja kaum ein gymnasium noch
wo nicht mindestens 50 prozent der 1,4
dem komma haben also dass das ist
diese ungedeckten scheck aus was sie
hier machen ist oder ihrem plädoyer war
ja ein sehr vielschichtiges also einmal
ging es um die frage lässt sich und
bilder hat das ja auch noch mal
wiederholt oder auch aufgebraucht
alles bieten das ist vollkommen richtig
sie sind hierbei bild eine etwas
zugespitzte formulierung wie
beispielsweise hierbei bild gar nicht
mit dem gender stern schreiben das
machen viele andere so die sagen dann
auch eine kurze pause eine kunstpause
und sprechen dann weiter
das tun wir alles nicht und ich glaube
das ist auch gut so dass wir das nicht
tun weil einfach aussprache nicht
operiert werden darf schlimm reich
gehört der weise und nichtleben der
seriöserweise wenn an schulen so
geschrieben wird in offiziellen briefen
beispielsweise an die eltern die
eigentlich mit der offiziellen
schreibweise die die kinder lernen im
unterricht überhaupt nichts zu tun hat
bestes beispiel die einladung zum ersten
elternabend für erstklässler sternchen
innen die zufällig vor ein paar wochen
bei uns ins haus schwebte da fällt mir
nicht mehr viel zu ein ich glaube dass
erstklässler sternchen innen
so was von absolutismus
absolut daneben ist die erstklässler
wissen meistens gerade ob sie mit ihrer
junge sind was das sternchen da soll ist
mir völlig hat es bei wiedergegeben
völlig frage und dann glaube ich ist ein
wichtiger punkt den sie machen
wir schreiben aus ideologie oder an
schulen wird aus ideologischen gründen
vom lehrpersonal auch von der
schulleiterin und dem schulleiter anders
geschrieben als es offiziell gelehrt
wird und das ist da glaube ich zeigt
sich der ganze irrsinn und die ganzen
polizeiwägen analoge schädlich dieser
sprach mit
jan war ich glaube herr kraus sie haben
ja auch gemeint nicht nur was das
schulsystem betrifft generell der
deutschunterricht würde gerne einmal
hier zeigen es ist sehr tagesaktuell das
will ich auch ihnen nicht vorenthalten
lieber herr zuschauer und zwar karl
lauterbach was ihm gerade soja
beschäftigt
runde stehen und haben dazu
geleistet
recht
[Applaus]
dann heißt es sein tag
hinausgeht stellen haben diese wichtig
dazu zu missbrauchen
den gearbeitet haben hier sicher
gelegentlich belastet sind ihre arbeit
hat keinen beirat
wenn man das hier gesehen hat dann merkt
man ja ganz klar herr lauterbach unser
gesundheitsminister also ein
bundesminister spricht eigentlich den
menschen das recht ab zur demonstration
gegen die impfung da würde ich gerne
einmal natürlich schon bilder aller
fragen nicht nur bei dem auftritt habe
ich mich gewundert in der vergangenheit
aber wie viel muss denn eigentlich passt
ja das muss jetzt gar nicht auffällt
aber bezogen sein bis ein minister
zurücktreten muss gibt es eigentlich
irgendwer den auch die bevölkerung hat
wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel keine
untertanen mehr sein wollen und sagen
jetzt reicht's lauterbach ja wenn der
widerstand so groß ist dass ein
bundeskanzler oder bundeskanzlerin fühlt
das ist eine wahnsinnige belastung und
das wird sich auch nicht ändern dann
würde sie mir den hinweis geben jetzt
ist zeit oder den befehl oder wenn der
mann oder die frau tatsächlich zu
bedrohungen für die regierung wird dann
dann führt man ein solches gespräch in
diesem konkreten fall sehen will ich
glaube zwei sachen einen rhetorischen
trick von karl lauterbach er steht da
auf einer bühne wird ausgepfiffen
versucht diejenigen die ihn auspfeifen
verteilen diejenigen die ein
berechtigtes interesse haben sagt er und
diejenigen die ein berechtigtes
interesse haben ich finde dass fast in
form tatsächlich was er gemacht mit
denjenigen die die meinung vertreten
dass
impfen nebenwirkungen haben kann er sagt
ihr habt gar nichts dazu beigetragen die
situation zu verbessern wenn ich das
jetzt gerade so richtig mitgenommen habe
was dem kurzen clip und das ist
natürlich so jeder kennt natürlich
beispiele wo impfungen nebenwirkungen
gehabt haben ich kenne solche fälle ich
denke jeder von uns kennt sie zum
zweiten gibt es unglaublich viele
menschen die ein berechtigte sorge
hatten dass ihre kinder geimpft werden
ich gehe selber solche fälle das sind
kein geschlecht menschen die haben es
auch nicht verdient von karl lauterbach
hier beschimpft zu werden sondern wir
haben das in einer inneren überzeugung
gemacht dagegen kann man sein aber man
darf die leute und diese meinung
ich habe da auch dazugelernt aber nicht
nicht so in den senkel stellen wie er es
gemacht hat zumal nicht als
gesundheitsminister da gilt hat auch die
freiheit der anderen und das geht
überhaupt nicht
die müssen nicht viel hinzuzufügen würde
ich sagen das ist absolut richtig aber
das ist glaube ich etwas was wir bei
karl lauterbach ja eigentlich schon über
monate wenn ich vielleicht sogar über
jahre beobachten können und karl
lauterbach hat eigentlich das große
megathema corona r kämpft derzeit um
anerkennung und versucht dieses thema
corona durch einen sommer zu ziehen
indem überhaupt keine lust auf corona
hat in dem es auch übrigens in seinem
ressort ganz ganz viele andere probleme
gibt die zu regeln sind beispielsweise
das thema krankenkassenfinanzen also der
gesundheitsminister das hat man ja bei
jens spahn auch schon gesehen der hat ja
nicht nur eigentlich mit corona zu tun
er hat so viel anderes zu tun da geht es
um krankenhausfinanzierung da geht es um
die kassen finanzierung es gibt die
pharma branche es gibt auch die privaten
krankenversicherung beispielsweise es
gibt die ärzte die zahl ist also ist es
ein so vielschichtiges feld und karl
lauterbach das ehrt ihn liest ganz ganz
viele studien nachts was nicht so gut es
war recht arbeiten und nachts über
kümmert er sich um krone aber das andere
liegt brach und da wächst auch selbst in
der eigenen fraktion sogar in der
eigenen spd fraktion der unmut über karl
lauterbach weil er einfach nur ja was
ist ja mister corona ist aber nicht der
gesundheitsminister den dieses land
eigentlich bräuchte aber wie wenn du
dass gerade sie ist die demonstration
ist er die these der deutsch untertan
das weiß ich noch auf die korona
abmahnungen bezogen aber sind denn
eigentlich die deutschen dann überhaupt
so untertänig wie hast du das denn in
der kroner pandemie wahrgenommen auch
mit blick auf die künstler für
schauspieler sie auch viel weggefallen
ich glaube einfach dass erst mal viele
unsicher waren keiner wusste auch
wirklich wie er damit umgehen soll und
ich finde also das was herr lauterbach
da von sich gegeben hat funktioniert so
einfach nicht also gerade als politiker
für mich hast du ganz kleine
vorbildfunktion auch und leute da so
immens auszugrenzen wo ja immer noch
viele unsicherheiten haben das
funktioniert hättest du dich als
schauspielerin getraut demonstrieren zu
gehen als person des öffentlichen lebens
in der zeit des winters und wo es so
stark zugespitzt hat in deutschland du
meinst wenn ich mich nicht hätte impfen
lassen wollen ja
auf jeden fall warum dann nicht wenn ich
dagegen bin und wirklich auch angst
davor habe auf jeden fall ist es wichtig
da seine stimme
ergreift was ich aus und wenig ist es
hier gar nicht frau wolff die
schauspieler werde demonstrieren
gegangen wenn sie gegen die impfung
gewesen wäre die menschen demonstrieren
gegen er laut dabei ich glaube ich habe
da
eine differenzierte meinung gefunden ich
war zweimal geimpft werden impft
durchbruch gehabt mit der heftigen
lungenentzündung und mein jüngster
bruder ist klinikchef und dem 120 leute
gestorben also ich will da schon
differenzieren ja was mich an lauterbach
stört ist also mit angst arbeitet das
andere meinungen nicht geltenlässt
wegwischt dass er mit angst arbeitet ich
habe in dem buch unter anderem auch den
begriff der fotografie geprägt wo und
generalisierte angst und kathi damit
damit herrschen damit herr spart damit
kann man natürlich den deutschen mittel
ähnlicher sich mit der ganzen liga die
partie verfolgt ja
wir werden hat er ja auch gesagt war
künstlich
meeresspiegel mit uns sieben meter
steigen oder glaube ich letztlich sogar
mehr losgelassen und er vergisst aber
auch schnell was er bevor er sich über
die talkshows ins ministeramt ihn
eingelagert hat muss man so bis
formulieren ja er vergisst schnell thema
hospitalisierung rate dass er im
aufsichtsrat der rhön kliniken und in
gutachten für die bertelsmann-stiftung
noch bevor er minister wurde gesagt hat
wir können uns ein wir können als die
hälfte von den 1800 klinik in
deutschland sparen ja wir können sie
schließt sozusagen ja also da darf es an
glaubwürdigkeit ganz zu schweigen davon
er ist ja auch schon aufgetreten mit
studien auf der basis von zwei versucht
für so einander putzig wenn ich glaube
das ist ein sehr gutes schloss satz für
ihre these